dagmar meyer erwartet uns seit mehr als
einem halben jahr stehen wir in kontakt
und heute ist sie stark genug zu reden
vor einer kamera
vor wenigen stunden haben sie und ihr
mann jens ausgesagt vor gericht gegen
den attentäter von halle
ich sag mal so in tränen ausgebrochen
bin ich als jens dann runter kam der
bisher zuerst aussagen sind alles noch
mal hoch der neunte oktober 2009 10 ein
rechts terrorist versucht in einer
synagoge in halle ein blutbad
anzurichten r scheitert
auf seiner flucht erschießt er zwei
menschen mit kaputten reifen fährt er in
den ort wie das dorf sucht einen neuen
fluchtwagen ein grüner polo gehört
dagmar mersmann jens als der sich
weigert den wagen herauszugeben schießt
der täter ihm in den hals von mir
untergekommen
da war jens aber schon fast vorne an der
tür und ich nur gesehen dass der voller
blut war hinterher also da bin ich habe
wirklich gelaufen und hier habe ich dann
auf der nase gelegen wusste nicht warum
der täter hatte dagmar mönkemeyer von
hinten ins bein geschossen mit einer
selbstgebauten waffe die
konstruktionspläne aus dem internet ich
hab das ja auch erst mal gar nicht
wirklich als wackel frage das war ja
irgendwie ich stelle mir eine pistole
anderswo und da ist ja an mir vorbei
weg war
er ist garant sozusagen nein gelaufen
nein ganz gemütlich hier aus dagmar
meyer und ihr mann drohen zu verbluten
sie erzählt sie habe schwer verletzt an
einer tür gelehnt und den notruf gewählt
und später das blut mit silber farbe
überpinselt hab dann ja erstmal die 11
10 gewährt so vorlaut du also ein
solcher sachen kann ich mich erinnern
und dann die 110
dann musste ich gefühlt 100 mal meinen
namen frontal21 konnte die notruf
protokolle einsehen
notruf der polizei winkelmeier wie das
dorf ist einer der hat auf uns
geschossen wir brauchen wo die wie das
dorf wie das ein anruf in der
polizeileitstelle im chaos des 9
oktober da ist ein mann mit glatze der
hatten gewehr der schießt mit hier
ich sag mal so nach 56 minuten also ich
hatte die leitstelle am ohr und der heli
flug hierüber und wir sollten gucken
wurde helios und winken
wir winken gut mein mann hat auch so
einen leon form eines t shirt an so so
ein arbeits t shirt wir haben beide hier
gestanden
es gab keine reaktion darauf wurde ist
nach dagmar münchen als erinnerung
dauert des anderthalb stunden bis sie in
der notaufnahme waren inzwischen
herrscht ausnahmezustand in widdersdorf
der täter hatte ein paar straßen weiter
ein taxi als fluchtwagen gekapert gut
eine halbe stunde später folgt die
verhaftung dagmar meyer hat sich der
anschlag eingebrannt eine zigarette
hilft um zu reden über das was sie ein
leben lang begleiten wird
wenn das jetzt mein bein ist und hier
mal hinter dann hat er hier
eingeschlossen
aber der muss dicht hinter mir gewesen
sein beide einfluss richtig relativ
gering
30 cm muss nicht den termin gewesen sein
und der hat den oberschenkel machen dass
ihr alles zu deppert dadurch habe ich
diese dynamische schraube und dieses
loch von der kogel das musst du langsam
von innen nach außen zurück
seit einem jahr können sie und ihr mann
nicht mehr arbeiten und kaum noch
schlafen was ich schreib das oft nach 10
was ich jetzt mache weiß ich gar nicht
aber klar man denkt man hat ja irgendwo
existenzängste weil das ist völlig für
das konnten das läuft im frühjahr aus
oder
als wir uns verabschieden hat dagmar
meyer ein wunsch dass sie ihr mann und
der kleine ort wie das dorf nicht
vergessen werden
beim gedenken an den anschlag von halle
[Musik]